Avant que la vidéo ne commence,
j’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de dix secondes,
donc faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail
après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Je vous laisse regarder la vidéo,
et moi je vais promener Haristote.
________________
1ère référence : La République, Platon
Pourquoi cette référence est-elle incontournable
?
Eh bien La République de Platon est peut-être
le livre le plus célèbre de la philosophie
occidentale. C’est en tout cas la référence
la plus importante de la philosophie POLITIQUE,
c’est-à-dire la partie de la philosophie
qui traite de l’organisation de la vie collective.
Ce livre a eu une IMMENSE influence dans l’histoire
de la pensée.
Comme les autres œuvres de Platon, La République
a une forme particulière : ce n’est pas
un long développement, un long discours — non,
c’est la retranscription d’une interaction
sociale, un dialogue entre Socrate, qui était
le maître de Platon, et un auditoire réduit
d’Athéniens privilégiés. Et donc on découvre
différentes idées par les voix de différents
interlocuteurs. Historiquement, cet échange
s’est produit à Athènes, au Ve siècle
avant J.-C.
Que retenir concernant le fond, maintenant
?
Retenez déjà que La République appartient
au genre littéraire de l’UTOPIE : c’est
une description concrète et détaillée de
l’organisation idéale d’une société
humaine. Platon imagine une cité dont le
but est de réaliser la justice, qu’il définit
comme l’harmonie des parties dans le tout.
Pour le dire en un mot, la justice c’est
la cohérence, ou la cohésion.
Comment la cité imaginée par Platon réalise-t-elle
l’harmonie ?
Grâce à deux facteurs :
— 1er facteur : la cité idéale divise
les citoyens en 3 catégories, les gardiens
(les gouvernants), les auxiliaires (les guerriers)
et les producteurs (tous les autres). Chaque
groupe doit remplir sa fonction, et uniquement
cette fonction, et chaque citoyen doit être
dans la bonne position hiérarchique par rapport
aux autres.
— 2nd facteur de l’harmonie sociale : la
cité idéale de Platon donne le pouvoir à
une élite de philosophes qui vivent ensemble
selon des principes communistes. C’est ce
qu’on appelle la théorie du « philosophe
roi ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, allez lire
mon résumé détaillé sur 1000 idées de
culture générale (le lien est dans la description).
________________
2ème référence : Le Banquet, Platon
Platon est, avec son élève Aristote, le
plus grand philosophe de la tradition intellectuelle
occidentale, donc il mérite bien une seconde
place dans cette liste (Aristote en prendra
deux lui aussi).
Pourquoi est-ce que Le Banquet est une référence
philosophique incontournable ?
Pour faire simple, on considère que ce livre
est à l’origine de notre conception de
l’amour. L’idée que l’amour c’est
une expérience transcendante, c’est-à-dire
une expérience qui nous sort de la banalité
du quotidien, qui nous transporte et qui nous
élève, presque une expérience mystique,
une expérience religieuse qui nous élève
vers des sphères divines — cette idée
importante a son origine dans Le Banquet de
Platon.
Sur le plan de la forme littéraire, c’est
la même chose que dans La République : Socrate
et des Athéniens aisés parlent ensemble
de l’amour et de la beauté.
C’est quoi, l’essentiel, sur le fond ?
Platon rejette l'idée que l'amour est une
question de désir et de satisfaction sexuelle.
Il ne pense pas non plus, contrairement à
nous, que le rapprochement des corps peut
servir le rapprochement des cœurs. Pour lui,
aimer quelqu’un, c’est aimer son âme,
ou plus précisément, c’est aimer le voir
perfectionner son âme.
Certains philosophes humanistes du XVe siècle
reliront Le Banquet de Platon dans le paradigme
du christianisme et théoriseront ce qu’on
appelle « l’amour platonique » : un amour
qui exclut par définition la sensualité,
un amour tout entier consacré à la culture
de l’esprit et à l’affinité des âmes.
J’ai lu ce livre, mais je n’ai pas encore
trouvé le temps de le résumer. Si vous regardez
cette vidéo plusieurs mois ou plusieurs années
après sa publication, regardez dans la description
ou directement sur le site, et peut-être
que vous trouverez mon résumé détaillé
du Banquet de Platon.
En revanche, ma synthèse de la théorie de
l’amour platonique est déjà disponible
(le lien est dans la description).
________________
3ème référence : Les Politiques, Aristote
On passe donc, comme promis, à Aristote,
le plus célèbre disciple de Platon.
Le 1er livre qui mérite sa place dans cette
liste, c’est Les Politiques, qu’on nomme
aussi parfois la Politique. C’est une référence
incontournable parce qu’elle a eu une influence
considérable sur la manière dont les Occidentaux
organisent leur vie collective. Contrairement
à La République de Platon, ce livre propose
une réflexion réaliste et pragmatique sur
le problème de l’harmonie sociale.
Il s’en distingue également sur la forme.
Les Politiques, ce n’est pas un dialogue
; c’est un traité qui rassemble diverses
leçons de philosophie politique qu’Aristote
avait données dans son école, le Lycée.
Qu’en retenir, sur le plan des idées ?
Deux idées ont particulièrement marqué
la culture occidentale.
— La première, c’est celle de la fameuse
formule : l’homme est un « animal politique
».
Pour Aristote, ce n’est pas un hasard si
l’être humain possède le langage. Comme
cette faculté lui permet de coopérer avec
une sophistication bien supérieure à celle
des autres animaux, cette faculté signifie
que l’homme accomplit sa nature en vivant
en communauté et en perfectionnant l’organisation
de cette vie collective.
Contrairement aux sophistes, qui rejetaient
la Cité dans la convention ou l’artifice,
Aristote pense que c’est une organisation
naturelle.
— La seconde idée du livre qui a marqué
la culture occidentale, c’est la légitimation
de l’esclavage.
Aristote affirme que certains hommes sont
naturellement inférieurs aux autres, c’est
pourquoi ils sont voués à subir l’autorité
d’un maître et à lui servir d’instrument.
Cette idée est controversée, mais l’esclavage
était une réalité sociale de l’Antiquité.
Aristote considère ainsi que l’homme libre
citoyen de la Cité doit s’épargner toutes
les tâches qui l’éloigneraient de la vie
politique ou de la philosophie en les donnant
à faire à des esclaves, et en déléguant
à un intendant le soin de leur commander.
________________
4ème référence : Éthique à Nicomaque,
Aristote
Comme son titre l’indique, ce livre parle
d’éthique, c’est-à-dire de la conduite
idéale des hommes. « Nicomaque » est le
prénom du fils d’Aristote. Contrairement
à ce qu’on peut croire, le père n’a
pas dédicacé le livre au fils — c’est
le fils qui a édité l’ouvrage après la
mort du père, d’où la présence de son
prénom dans le titre.
Sur la forme, c’est encore un traité qui
rassemble des réflexions plus ou moins longues.
Je l’ai lu en entier, et honnêtement, il
faut parfois s’accrocher (je pense que c’est
en partie dû à des questions de traduction).
Sur le fond, il y a dans l’Éthique à Nicomaque
deux idées importantes pour votre culture
générale : la conception du bonheur d’Aristote,
et sa conception de l’amitié (qui sera
influente dans la tradition occidentale).
Alors, c’est quoi le bonheur, pour Aristote
?
Il commence par dire ce que le bonheur n’est
pas. Il pose tout d’abord que ce ne sont
pas les biens extérieurs, comme la richesse
ou la gloire, qui rendent l’homme heureux.
« On confond, dit-il, le bonheur avec le
succès et l’honnêteté. » Il reproche
ensuite à Platon de concevoir un bonheur
impossible à atteindre avec sa théorie des
Idées.
Pour trouver ce que le bonheur est, Aristote
tire la nature du bien général à partir
de celle d’un bien particulier. Tout comme
le bien du médecin, de l’artisan, ou du
musicien consiste à bien exécuter sa fonction,
le bien de l’homme en général consiste
à vivre selon le bien, c’est-à-dire à
être vertueux.
Ça c’est pour la théorie — en pratique,
le bonheur tient à 3 choses, conclut Aristote
: pratiquer la vertu ; avoir le minimum des
biens extérieurs (parce que c’est difficile
d’être heureux dans la misère) ; et enfin,
pouvoir compter sur une prospérité durable.
Je passe maintenant à l’idée de l’amitié.
Pour Aristote, on ne peut aimer avec pureté
que dans la « vraie » amitié. Mais qu’est-ce
que la « vraie » amitié ? Eh bien déjà
ce n’est ni l’amitié d’intérêt (qui
concerne plutôt les vieux) ni l’amitié
de plaisir (qui concerne plutôt les jeunes).
La véritable amitié se forge avec le temps
: « La volonté d'être amis peut être rapide,
mais l'amitié ne l'est point », prévient
Aristote. Alors, comment définir l’amitié
? C’est le lien qui unit deux personnes
vertueuses qui, chacune, estiment la vertu
de l’autre.
L’œuvre d’Aristote est importante (même
si une partie a été perdue), et il a eu
beaucoup d’idées brillantes. Si vous voulez
découvrir ces idées brillantes, allez sur
le site 1000 idées de culture générale
et tapez « Aristote » dans la barre de recherche.
________________
5ème référence : Lettre à Ménécée,
Épicure
Pourquoi cette référence est-elle importante
?
Parce que c’est l’ouvrage de référence
de l’épicurisme, une des deux grandes écoles
philosophiques de l’Antiquité après les
3 « monstres » Socrate, Platon et Aristote
(l’autre grande école philosophique de
l’Antiquité, c’est le stoïcisme).
La Lettre à Ménécée est un petit livre
— c’est bien une lettre en fait — donc
vous pouvez la lire en entier. Elle est grosso
modo de la taille d’un long article sur
internet ; et puis le style et les idées
sont vraiment accessibles, donc n’hésitez
pas si vous voulez lire de la philosophie
dans le texte sans vous prendre la tête.
Sur le fond, la Lettre à Ménécée résume
la doctrine éthique d’Épicure, le fondateur
de l’épicurisme. Vous pouvez retenir 2
idées pour votre culture générale.
PREMIÈRE IDÉE, le bonheur passe par le plaisir.
Cette idée a valu à Épicure d’être caricaturé.
Les philosophes des écoles concurrentes (dont
les stoïciens), probablement jaloux de son
succès, le font passer pour un débauché.
Comment Épicure justifie-t-il, sur le fond,
la recherche du plaisir ? Eh bien le plaisir
est la finalité naturelle de la vie, car
les animaux comme les hommes recherchent naturellement
le plaisir et fuient la douleur, dès la naissance
et sans l’avoir appris.
Mais Épicure défend plus précisément la
frugalité. En premier lieu, il faut limiter
la quantité du plaisir, miser plutôt sur
la qualité et l’intensité. En second lieu,
il faut éteindre les désirs artificiels,
comme la quête de la richesse ou des honneurs.
Et puis parmi les désirs naturels, il faut
éteindre ceux qui, comme le désir sexuel,
les satisfactions esthétiques, ne sont nécessaires
ni à la survie ni au bonheur.
Épicure préconise en réalité de calculer
les plaisirs afin d’obtenir la jouissance
modérée et stable qui rend possible une
vie sage et heureuse.
SECONDE IDÉE IMPORTANTE de la Lettre à Ménécée,
la philosophie est la médecine de l’âme.
Épicure recommande d’appliquer ce qu’on
appelle le « quadruple remède des épicuriens
», ou Tetrapharmakos :
1. ne pas craindre les dieux ;
2. ne pas craindre la mort ;
3. viser le bonheur ;
4. supporter la douleur.
L’objectif est d’atteindre l’ataraxie,
c’est-à-dire la tranquillité de l’âme
qui n’est troublée ni par la crainte ni
par le désir. C’est dans l’absence de
trouble que réside le vrai plaisir.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur cette référence,
allez lire mon résumé détaillé sur 1000
idées de culture générale (le lien est
dans la description).
________________
6ème référence : Manuel, Épictète
Je passe maintenant à la seconde grande école
philosophique de l’Antiquité, le stoïcisme.
Le livre de référence n’est pas une œuvre
du fondateur de l’école, Zénon, mais un
résumé des cours d’Épictète, un esclave
qui vivait dans l’Empire romain au Ier siècle
après J.C. Son maître l’autorisait à
suivre les leçons d’un philosophe stoïcien,
donc il est devenu philosophe professionnel
une fois qu’il a été affranchi.
Pourquoi le Manuel d’Épictète est-il une
référence importante ?
Parce qu’il est probablement le texte stoïcien
qui a été le plus influent dans la culture
occidentale. Ses idées sont notamment passées
dans le christianisme, plus précisément
dans la spiritualité et la tradition monastique
chrétiennes.
Sur la forme, le propos frappe par sa grande
simplicité, par rapport à certains classiques
qui font passer la philosophie pour de la
masturbation intellectuelle. La sobriété
de l’éloquence d’Épictète, la simplicité
pédagogique de ses exemples et de ses images
faisaient d’ailleurs une profonde impression
sur son auditoire. La jeunesse romaine se
déplaçait en nombre pour écouter ses leçons.
Épictète était une star.
Sur le fond, son Manuel développe et illustre
les grands principes de la morale stoïcienne.
Le livre commence avec la formule culte du
détachement : « Il y a des choses qui dépendent
de nous ; il y en a d’autres qui n’en
dépendent pas ». L’idée est que nous
avons intérêt à concentrer nos ressources
— notre volonté, nos pensées, notre énergie
et nos actes — sur ce qui est en notre pouvoir.
Par exemple, il ne sert à rien de maudire
la pluie qui dure. En revanche, il n’est
pas vain de considérer notre santé, parce
que nous pouvons faire beaucoup de choses
pour l’améliorer. L’objectif de cet état
d’esprit, c’est que le bonheur de l’homme
dépende aussi peu que possible de causes
extérieures.
Épictète fait d’autres recommandations
moins typiquement stoïciennes, par exemple
s’exprimer avec parcimonie, en évitant
la vulgarité et en ménageant les sentiments
des interlocuteurs ; ou encore limiter les
soins du corps à la plus stricte utilité.
Cette discipline montre bien que pour Épictète,
la philosophie n’est pas une science, une
discipline intellectuelle, mais un mode de
vie encadré par des principes de sagesse.
À la fin du Manuel, il recommande de commencer
par APPLIQUER les maximes philosophiques,
avant de vouloir s’occuper de théorie.
Il conseille de s’inspirer de l’exemple
de Socrate.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur cette référence,
allez lire mon résumé détaillé sur 1000
idées de culture générale (le lien est
dans la description).
________________
7ème référence : Somme théologique, Thomas
d’Aquin
La Somme théologique est l’ouvrage de référence
de la philosophie dite « scolastique », c’est-à-dire
la philosophie produite en Occident au Moyen
Âge par le système académique lié à l’Église.
La Somme théologique était un manuel de
théologie à destination des étudiants — autant
dire que ce n’est pas le genre de livre
qu’on emporte en vacances.
L’auteur, Thomas d’Aquin, est un religieux
italien du XIIIe siècle qui a également
étudié à Paris. Il paraît qu’il était
très gentil. Il est le plus célèbre penseur
de la philosophie et de la théologie scolastiques.
Je vais parler brièvement du contenu de la
Somme théologique parce que son intérêt
est limité pour une culture générale moderne,
c’est-à-dire une culture générale qui
nous permet de comprendre le monde actuel,
dans lequel nous vivons, et de donner un sens
à notre existence présente.
Alors, quoi retenir de ce livre ?
La 1ère chose intéressante, c’est que
la réflexion de la Somme théologique témoigne
de l’effort intellectuel de l’époque
pour combiner la Bible et la pensée d’Aristote,
et plus généralement la théologie et la
philosophie.
D’ailleurs, l’idée centrale du livre
est qu’il faut combiner la foi et la raison.
Pour donner du crédit à son propos, Thomas
d'Aquin s'appuie sur des affirmations et des
preuves tirées de la Bible, mais aussi de
textes juifs, païens grecs, et même islamiques.
La 2nde chose intéressante dans la Somme
théologique, c’est la réflexion de Thomas
d’Aquin sur les preuves de l’existence
de Dieu. À ses yeux, les preuves de nature
subjective, ou psychologique ne valent rien.
Il distingue, lui, 5 manières différentes
de prendre conscience de l’existence de
Dieu PAR LA RAISON. C’est ce qu’on appelle
en latin les quinque viae, c’est-à-dire
les « cinq voies ».
Voici donc les 5 preuves de l’existence
de Dieu :
1. il existe un moteur immobile de l’univers
;
2. il existe également une cause première
3. il existe forcément une entité nécessaire
en elle-même ;
4. il existe forcément un être absolument
parfait ;
5. l’ordre du monde présuppose une intelligence
ordonnatrice.
La Somme théologique a certes un intérêt
limité pour votre culture générale, mais
elle est une référence fondamentale de la
pensée chrétienne. L’Église a canonisé
Thomas d’Aquin en reconnaissant à la fois
son importance pour la scolastique et sa sainteté.
Et il a inspiré un courant philosophico-politique
qui se réclame de lui, le « thomisme ».
________________
8ème référence : Le Prince, Machiavel
Cette référence de philosophie politique
est importante parce qu’elle est à l’origine
de ce qu’on appelle le « machiavélisme
», l’idée qu’il faut exercer le pouvoir
politique en excluant les considérations
morales. Elle a également donné l’épithète
« machiavélique », qui caractérise une
personne manipulatrice qui n’hésite pas
à s’affranchir de la morale pour parvenir
à ses fins. Dans les années 1970, des psychologues
ont même fait du machiavélisme une composante
de certains troubles de la personnalité et
ils ont créé une échelle du machiavélisme
qui va de 0 à 100 (plus vous êtes haut,
plus vous êtes une personne à fuir).
Machiavel était un Italien qui a vécu entre
les XVe et XVIe siècles. Contrairement aux
philosophes antérieurs, il part du principe
que l’action politique doit être jugée
à ses seuls résultats et indépendamment
des moyens employés. C’est en cela qu’il
choque. Il faut dire qu’il était un homme
de terrain : il s’est mis à l’écriture
après une carrière dans la diplomatie, où
il a pu observer de près la mécanique du
pouvoir.
En 1513, il rédige Le Prince à l’intention
de Julien et de Laurent de Médicis (qui sont
alors au pouvoir à Florence). Il espère
un emploi des deux dirigeants, mais ceux-ci
n’ont sans doute jamais lu l’ouvrage.
Qu’en retenir ? Il y a deux idées importantes.
PREMIÈRE IDÉE — Le pragmatisme est la
meilleure manière d’exercer le pouvoir.
Machiavel débarrasse la politique des scrupules
juridiques et moraux qui restreignaient, voire
paralysaient l’action de l’État au Moyen
Âge. À ses yeux, la conduite des affaires
doit être guidée par de pures considérations
pratiques, afin de maintenir un équilibre,
même précaire, des intérêts qui sont en
conflit dans la société.
SECONDE IDÉE — Ce que Machiavel appelle
la « fortune » (il ne s’agit pas du compte
en banque) — la fortune, c’est-à-dire
le hasard dans le cours des événements,
est toute-puissante. Machiavel explique dans
Le Prince (notamment) que l’homme ne peut
pas avoir le contrôle du cours des choses,
car sa raison est impuissante à anticiper
la tournure des événements. Malgré la forte
ressemblance du passé et du futur, les phénomènes
politiques sont caractérisés par une irrégularité
qui demande au dirigeant une grande faculté
d’adaptation pour réussir en politique,
ce que Machiavel appelle la virtu. C’est
à propos de cette faculté d’adaptation
qu’il évoque la célèbre métaphore du
lion et du renard. Je le cite : « Il faut
donc être renard pour connaître les pièges
et lion pour effrayer les loups ».
Les caricatures de la pensée de Machiavel
confondent souvent l’immoralisme, c’est-à-dire
la contestation, voire le renversement de
la morale établie, et d’autre part l’amoralisme,
qui consiste à s’émanciper des considérations
morales. Or, Machiavel ne préconise pas de
faire le mal — il dit que le résultat est
la seule chose qui compte, et que le dirigeant
doit donc être prêt à défendre son intérêt
coûte que coûte.
________________
9ème référence : Les Essais, Montaigne
Pourquoi cette référence est-elle importante
?
Les Essais représentent une rupture culturelle
en raison de leur prétention à l’universalité
: Montaigne peint sa propre âme en détail,
mais chaque lecteur s’y retrouve. Tout le
propos répond à une seule question fondamentale
: « qu’est-ce que l’homme ? ».
« Qui se connaît, connaît aussi les autres,
écrit Montaigne, car chaque homme porte la
forme entière de l’humaine condition. »
C’est cette perspective intellectuelle,
caractéristique de l’humanisme, qui fait
de Montaigne le plus grand écrivain et philosophe
de la Renaissance.
Sur la forme, les 3 livres des Essais sont
une compilation de courts textes. Le style
est direct, vivant, humoristique, et parfois
paillard et grossier. Montaigne se promène
d'un sujet à l'autre comme s’il conversait
avec le lecteur. S’il cite souvent les philosophes
de l’Antiquité, il fait aussi confiance
à son propre jugement.
Sur le fond, il y a 2 éléments importants
pour votre culture générale.
PREMIER ÉLÉMENT — La barbarie est une
illusion. Le mot « barbarie » possède une
connotation péjorative qui dénote la sauvagerie
et la cruauté. Il sert à qualifier les peuples
qui n’appartiennent pas à une culture donnée
; or, cela présuppose que cette culture pense
qu’elle est la seule à posséder des mœurs
parfaites et morales. Montaigne donne en exemple
la prise de conscience des rois Pyrrhus et
Philippe, respectivement rois de Perse et
de Macédoine — ils ont pris conscience,
face à la sophistication militaire romaine,
que tout ce qui n’est pas grec n’est pas
forcément barbare. Ainsi, chacun est l’étranger,
donc le barbare de l’autre. « Chacun appelle
barbarie ce qui n’est pas de son usage », écrit
Montaigne dans Les Essais.
SECOND ÉLÉMENT (important pour votre culture
générale) — La vérité est une illusion.
Si Montaigne s’inscrit dans la tradition
sceptique de l’Antiquité — dont il fait
d’ailleurs un exposé assez fidèle — il
propose un scepticisme moderne dans Les Essais.
Refusant les dogmes et les théories, il voit
la même vanité chez les hommes de science
les plus réputés et chez les faiseurs de
miracles. Il condamne toute science fondée
sur des principes fixes. À ses yeux, de tels
principes servent bien davantage le prestige
des savants de profession que la recherche
de la vérité. Pour se rapprocher de la vérité,
il faut apprendre à penser contre soi-même,
c’est-à-dire pratiquer ce qu’on appelle
« l’alternance du jugement ».
________________
10ème référence : Discours de la méthode,
Descartes
Le Discours de la méthode de Descartes est
un des livres les plus importants de toute
l’histoire de la philosophie. C’est la
source philosophique de la méthode scientifique
moderne et de notre idéal de la science — c’est
pour ça que l’on dit d’une personne rigoureuse
qu’elle est « cartésienne ». En France,
Descartes intègrera même la mythologie nationale
au XIXe siècle, car son œuvre, et en particulier
le Discours de la méthode, incarnerait l’ESPRIT
français : Descartes, c’est un peu la science
à la française.
Descartes était lui-même un véritable scientifique.
Il était un des meilleurs mathématiciens
de son temps. Il a également élaboré des
théories physiques. Et enfin, il n’était
pas seulement un théoricien, il était aussi
un expérimentateur.
C’est d’ailleurs pour cette raison qu’il
écrit le Discours de la méthode. Il a besoin
d’argent pour accélérer le rythme de ses
recherches, en particulier en médecine. Il
espère donc que son livre, qui ressemble
à un ouvrage de vulgarisation, pourra séduire
de potentiels mécènes. Il est écrit en
français plutôt qu’en latin, la langue
scientifique et académique de l’époque,
parce qu’il s’adresse en priorité à
l’homme de bon sens.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées essentielles
du livre ?
Il y en a CINQ.
LA PREMIÈRE, c’est l’idée du doute.
Il s’agit, pour Descartes, du principe fondamental
de la réflexion scientifique. Il y a différents
niveaux de doute : le doute dit « empirique
» est celui de l’expérience philosophique
du quotidien ; le doute dit « méthodique
» est l’instrument intellectuel pour fonder
la certitude ; et enfin, le doute dit « hyperbolique
» est un doute extrême, celui qui sert à
remettre en cause jusqu’à l’expérience
de la réalité et les principes qui sous-tendent
la connaissance.
LA DEUXIÈME IDÉE ESSENTIELLE du Discours
de la méthode, c’est ce qu’on appelle
le Cogito. Le mot vient de la locution latine
Cogito, ergo sum, qui signifie « Je pense,
donc je suis ». Pour comprendre son sens,
il faut partir du doute. L’exercice du doute
rend UNE CHOSE certaine : il n’est pas possible
de douter du fait même que l’on est en
train de douter. L’acte de douter, donc
l’acte de penser existe bien ; et par conséquent
l’acteur, c’est-à-dire le sujet pensant,
existe bien également. C’est ce raisonnement
qui conduit Descartes à dire Cogito ergo
sum, « Je pense donc je suis ».
LA TROISIÈME IDÉE ESSENTIELLE, c’est la
méthode scientifique. Pour Descartes, le
progrès de la connaissance repose sur une
méthode de raisonnement composée de quatre
règles à appliquer successivement : celle
de ÉVIDENCE des objets intellectuels à
partir desquels on réfléchit ; celle de
la DÉCOMPOSITION du problème intellectuel
; celle de la MISE EN ORDRE des pensées ; et
enfin celle de la VÉRIFICATION des éléments
du raisonnement.
LA QUATRIÈME IDÉE ESSENTIELLE du Discours
de la méthode, c’est celle de la maîtrise
de la nature. À la fin du livre, Descartes
parle de l’homme armé de la science comme
« maître et possesseur de la nature ». Alors
que la philosophie prônait le savoir pour
le savoir, il entrevoit lui l’émergence
d’un savoir pour pouvoir, c’est-à-dire
d’une science qui vise l’efficacité technique.
LA CINQUIÈME ET DERNIÈRE idée essentielle,
c’est ce que Descartes appelle sa « morale
provisoire ». Comparant son ambition de refonder
la science à la reconstruction d’une maison
qu’on a détruite, il en déduit qu’il
a besoin d’un logement provisoire pendant
les travaux. Il élabore donc une morale provisoire
(ou « morale par provision ») pour immuniser
son existence quotidienne contre le doute
qu’il cultive dans ses méditations.
Voici les 4 maximes de cette morale :
1. suivre les conventions de la société
;
2. agir fermement une fois une décision prise
3. adapter ses désirs à la réalité ;
4. choisir soigneusement la meilleure activité
pour sa vie.
C’est à propos de la 3ème maxime (« adapter
ses désirs à la réalité ») que Descartes
écrit sa célèbre formule stoïcienne : « Changer
ses désirs plutôt que l’ordre du monde
».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur cette référence,
allez lire mon résumé détaillé sur 1000
idées de culture générale (le lien est
dans la description).
________________
11ème référence : Léviathan, Thomas Hobbes
Pourquoi ce livre est-il si important ?
À la fois parce que c’est une référence
de la théorie du contrat social, et parce
qu’il sert à justifier l’octroi d’une
puissance exceptionnelle à l’État. Hobbes
fait référence au Léviathan, un monstre
marin colossal capable d’anéantir le monde,
parce qu’il veut que l’État ait les moyens
d’éteindre l’extrême instabilité de
l’état de nature.
Ce livre est un des textes fondateurs de la
philosophie politique au même titre que La
République de Platon, auquel Hobbes compare
d’ailleurs son travail.
Il faut quand même du courage pour le lire,
car c’est un bouquin de plus de 1000 pages.
Après, Hobbes, qui critique la masturbation
intellectuelle des penseurs scolastiques — Hobbes
fait, lui, l’effort de définir précisément
les termes qu’il emploie et de raisonner
avec rigueur. Il élabore une théorie scientifique
des lois morales et de l'organisation politique
avec une démarche inductive inspirée de
la géométrie (en géométrie, on observe
des figures concrètes et on en induit des
lois générales).
Le Léviathan est divisé en 4 parties, mais
l’essentiel à retenir pour votre culture
générale est concentré dans la 1ère partie,
intitulée « De l'Homme ».
Ce qui fait du livre une référence importante,
c’est que Hobbes y invente le mythe de la
souveraineté. Je résume ce mythe en une
phrase : les hommes ont reconnu l’autorité
d’un souverain absolu pour vivre dans la
sécurité.
Profondément marqué par les guerres intestines
qui ensanglantaient l'Angleterre de son époque,
Hobbes avait une vision pessimiste de la nature
humaine. À ses yeux, l’état de nature
de l’humanité est, je cite, « une guerre
de tous contre tous », où « l’homme est
un loup pour l’homme ». Comment sortir
de cette impasse ? Les hommes passent un contrat,
en vertu duquel ils créent un un souverain
absolu, un État illimité qui garantira la
paix publique grâce à la puissance de répression
dont il dispose. Telle est la solution qui
préserve la civilisation de la violence originelle.
Certains commentateurs estiment que cette
théorie met l’accent sur la nécessité
de protéger les individus, mais d’autres
reprochent au système de Hobbes de ne pas
être pluraliste (son souverain absolu ne
tolère pas la dissidence).
________________
12ème référence : Pensées, Pascal
Ce livre est une référence philosophique
importante parce que c’est une des méditations
les plus profondes sur le mystère de la vie
humaine. Il est aussi considéré comme un
des ouvrages les plus éloquents jamais écrits
en langue française.
En pratique, les Pensées sont une compilation
de réflexions et de notes de lecture. Après
une existence mondaine où il cherchait la
gloire par l'exploitation de ses recherches
scientifiques, Pascal a préparé une apologie
de la religion chrétienne. Comme il est mort
à 39 ans sans avoir pu mener à bien ce projet,
ce sont les éditeurs qui bouclé le livre.
Le résultat est un peu un traité de spiritualité.
Pascal était un scientifique de haut niveau
comme Descartes, mais contrairement à lui,
il souligne les limites de la pensée humaine,
et donc plus particulièrement de la raison.
Vous connaissez peut-être sa célèbre formule,
qui a même pénétré la culture populaire
: « Le cœur a ses raisons que la raison
ne connaît point ».
Quel est l’essentiel à retenir de la référence
?
Les Pensées contiennent 3 idées importantes
pour votre culture générale.
— La première est le divertissement. Pascal
explique que se divertir est une dimension
fondamentale, incontournable de l’existence
humaine. Les conversations, le jeu, la lecture
et mille autres moyens empêchent l'homme
de songer à la faiblesse de son moi. Seul
avec lui-même, il vivrait dans un ennui
insupportable.
— La deuxième idée importante est ce qu’on
appelle le « pari de Pascal », pari qui
concerne l’existence de Dieu. Le philosophe
avance qu’un homme rationnel a intérêt
à croire en Dieu, car s’il a raison, il
gagne le paradis, et s’il a tort, il ne
perd rien — tandis qu’en refusant de croire
en Dieu, il risque l’enfer s’il a tort.
— La troisième idée importante des Pensées
est la distinction entre ce que Pascal appelle
« l’esprit de géométrie » et « l’esprit
de finesse ». Ce sont 2 types d’intelligence
différents. L’esprit de géométrie, d’une
part, qui caractérise plutôt le scientifique,
consiste à découvrir les propriétés
communes des choses par des raisonnements
éloignés du sens commun. L’esprit de finesse,
d’autre part, qui est plutôt celui de l’homme
du monde, consiste à bien voir les choses
spontanément, sans raisonnement, presque
par intuition.
________________
13ème référence : Éthique, Spinoza
L'Éthique de Spinoza est le livre le plus
important de la philosophie éthique de l’époque
moderne, juste avant l’époque des Lumières.
Comme le titre l’indique, il s’agit bien
d’éthique, c’est-à-dire de la conduite
idéale des hommes, mais l’ouvrage ne se
limite pas à cette dimension. Spinoza se
livre à une critique impitoyable des conceptions
traditionnelles de Dieu, de l'être humain
et de l'univers, en particulier de celles
qui servent de fondement aux grandes religions
organisées et à leurs règles morales et
cérémonielles.
Mais il considère que le message crucial
de l’Éthique est de nature... éthique.
En effet, Spinoza a démystifié l’univers
parce qu’il veut convaincre le lecteur de
la cohérence entre sa vision de la conduite
idéale et la réalité de l’existence humaine.
Ce n’est qu’une fois que nous savons comment
le monde fonctionne vraiment que nous pouvons
en déduire comment nous y conduire. Voilà
pour le projet intellectuel du livre.
Sur la forme, le livre est particulièrement
difficile à lire, en particulier parce qu’il
est rédigé comme un traité de maths, avec
des listes d’axiomes, de définitions, etc.
Sur le fond, 2 idées se détachent.
— PREMIÈRE IDÉE : « Dieu ou la nature
», c’est-à-dire l’équivalence entre
Dieu et la nature. Le Dieu de Spinoza tranche
avec les conceptions monothéistes, ce qui
lui a valu pas mal de problèmes au cours
de sa vie (il a été excommunié par la communauté
juive d'Amsterdam et ensuite il a été victime
d’une tentative d’assassinat, ce dont
il a conclu que la religion mène à la folie
[on peut le comprendre]). Je reviens au fond.
Pour Spinoza, il n'existe dans la réalité
qu'une seule substance, infinie et unique,
confondue avec le monde. Par conséquent Dieu
est équivalent à la nature même, comme
l’exprime l’expression latine Deus sive
natura, « Dieu ou la nature ».
— SECONDE IDÉE importante de l’Éthique,
le conatus (qui signifie « effort » en latin).
L’idée est que chaque chose qui existe
est animée par une force qui la fait persévérer
dans son être et poursuivre son propre accroissement
— c’est cette force, le conatus. Spinoza
en déduit que le désir est l’essence de
l’homme. Le désir n’est donc pas une
menace, ce n’est pas forcément quelque
chose qui rabaisse l’homme. Pour autant,
l’homme doit se servir de sa raison afin
de ne pas devenir l’esclave du conatus.
Voici la conclusion ÉTHIQUE de Spinoza : le
bonheur réside dans la vie de la raison,
pas dans une vie asservie aux passions et
aux biens transitoires que nous recherchons
ordinairement, ni dans l'attachement irréfléchi
aux superstitions qui passent pour de la religion.
________________
14ème référence : Discours sur l’origine
de l’inégalité, Rousseau
Cette référence est importante parce qu’elle
est la plus célèbre et la plus éloquente
critique de la civilisation moderne. Elle
est aussi un peu la matrice de la philosophie
de Rousseau, car il y présente sa perspective
globale, il y affirme ses principales idées
et il y démontre l’originalité de sa voix
(notamment par rapport aux Lumières).
Rousseau écrit ce discours en 1755 pour répondre
à la question du concours de l’Académie
de Dijon : « Quelle est l’origine de l’inégalité
parmi les hommes, et si elle est autorisée
par la loi naturelle ? ». C’est le second
sujet de cette académie auquel il répond,
car il a déjà gagné le concours en 1750
avec son Discours sur les sciences et les
arts.
Le Discours sur l’origine de l’inégalité
est divisé en 2 parties, la première sur
l’homme à l’état de nature, et la seconde
sur le passage de l’état de nature à l’état
social de l’époque.
Sur la forme, c’est exceptionnellement bien
écrit. Rousseau est en effet un des plus
grands stylistes de la langue française.
Sa prose est si puissante que certains estiment
que c’est ce talent, plutôt que l’originalité
de ses idées (qui avaient en réalité déjà
été agitées par des auteurs antérieurs)
— ce serait l’éloquence de Rousseau,
pas ses idées, qui l’aurait rendu célèbre.
Peut-être, mais peut-être pas.
Que retenir sur le fond, maintenant ?
Trois idées sont particulièrement importantes.
PREMIÈRE IDÉE : l’état de nature — Rousseau
conçoit dans le Discours sur l’origine
de l’inégalité un état de nature, c’est-à-dire
un état présocial, dépourvu d’inégalité.
Cette conception lui permet de démontrer
que les inégalités criantes de son époque
ne sont pas naturelles, qu’elles sont le
produit de la seule société. À l’état
de nature, la vie humaine peut être brève,
mais elle est toujours heureuse. L’homme
naturel de Rousseau correspond au chasseur-cueilleur
qui, jouissant d’une relative abondance
naturelle, travaille peu.
DEUXIÈME IDÉE IMPORTANTE : la perfectibilité
— Alors que la tradition philosophique caractérisait
l’être humain par l’aptitude au discours
rationnel (ce qu’on appelle le logos), Rousseau
avance dans le Discours sur l’inégalité
que la spécificité de l’homme est sa capacité
à évoluer. Contrairement à l’animal,
l’homme est ouvert et disponible au changement.
Mais malgré ce que suggère l’étymologie
(le latin perficere signifie « terminer,
perfectionner »), la perfectibilité n’est
pas un bien, car elle sort l’homme de sa
béatitude de l’état de nature et elle
le précipite dans les malheurs de la vie
sociale.
Plus profondément, la perfectibilité est
la condition de possibilité de l’histoire
elle-même — puisque si l’homme ne change
pas, alors il n’a pas d’histoire. Pour
Rousseau, l’être humain a notamment évolué
en développant la capacité à vivre en société,
et de cette nouvelle capacité ont découlé
les inventions de l’agriculture, de la métallurgie,
de la propriété, la division du travail
et l’émergence de l’État.
Dans cet enchaînement, c’est la propriété
privée, estime Rousseau, qui a véritablement
fondé la société civile. Vous connaissez
peut-être la célèbre phrase du Discours
sur l’inégalité : « Le premier qui, ayant
enclos un terrain, s’avisa de dire : Ceci
est à moi, et trouva des gens assez simples
pour le croire, fut le vrai fondateur de la
société civile ».
LA TROISIÈME ET DERNIÈRE IDÉE IMPORTANTE
concerne l’évolution psychologique de l’homme
dans le passage de l’état de nature à
l’état social. À l’état de nature,
l’homme est animé par ce que Rousseau appelle
« l’amour de soi », l’instinct animal
de conservation. Mais la perfectibilité entraîne
la dégradation de l’amour de soi. Les désirs
se surajoutent aux besoins et le paraître
se substitue à l’être : ainsi naît ce
que Rousseau appelle « l’amour-propre ». L’individu
n’est plus indépendant comme dans son état
sauvage, il est désormais sensible au regard
des autres, ce qui corrompt sa psychologie
et son comportement. Obsédé par la hiérarchie
sociale, il abandonne la simplicité naturelle,
il oublie l’essentiel et se préoccupe de
tous les artifices qui naissent dans la vie
sociale.
Ce diagnostic inspirera à beaucoup d’écrivains
(le russe Tolstoï, par exemple) l’idée
de la supériorité morale de la nature sur
tous les raffinements de la culture.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur cette référence,
allez lire mon résumé détaillé sur 1000
idées de culture générale (le lien est
dans la description).
________________
15ème référence : Critique de la raison
pure, Kant
Cette référence est TRÈS importante parce
qu’elle représente une rupture dans l’histoire
de la pensée. Avant ce livre, les philosophes
élaboraient des systèmes sans même s’interroger
sur la capacité de la raison humaine à produire
des connaissances fiables. Après la Critique
de la raison pure, les penseurs ne peuvent
plus négliger le rôle de l’esprit dans
la structuration de l’expérience. Ce livre
est le plus profond de la liste — et ce
n’est pas étonnant, parce que Kant a mis
15 ans à l’écrire.
Sur la forme, il faut s’accrocher parce
que Kant construit ses théories jusque dans
les détails et parce qu’il élabore pour
cela une terminologie compliquée (rassurez-vous
je vais vous épargner cette terminologie).
Après, ce n’est pas non plus illisible
comme Hegel.
Je vais vous expliquer simplement l’essentiel.
Quel est le but du livre ? La Critique de
la raison pure examine les limites de la raison.
Par « raison pure », il faut comprendre
la connaissance indépendante des sens, c’est-à-dire
la connaissance liée à la seule structure
de l’esprit. Kant estime que cette structure
de l’esprit, que l’origine et l’évolution
des concepts sont LE VRAI PROBLÈME de ce
qu’on appelle la métaphysique, c’est-à-dire
de la partie de la philosophie qui s’intéresse
aux essences des choses (par opposition aux
apparences). « Nous ne connaissons a priori
des choses, écrit Kant, que ce que nous y
mettons nous-mêmes. »
​​Voici maintenant les 3 idées importantes
de la Critique de la raison pure.
PREMIÈRE IDÉE : c’est le sujet pensant,
et non pas l’objet, qui est au centre de
la connaissance. Kant pense que l’esprit
intervient activement dans l’élaboration
de la connaissance, autrement dit qu’il
construit lui-même le réel. On dit à ce
propos que la théorie kantienne opère une
« révolution copernicienne » en philosophie
: tout comme Copernic a découvert que c’est
la Terre qui tourne autour du soleil — et
non l’inverse — Kant recentre la connaissance
sur le sujet pensant, plutôt que sur l’objet.
DEUXIÈME IDÉE IMPORTANTE de la Critique
de la raison pure : la pensée ordonne le
réel. Kant met en évidence les cadres universels
et nécessaires à travers lesquels l’esprit
humain saisit le monde. Notre esprit fonctionne
notamment avec 2 facultés : la sensibilité,
tout d’abord, reçoit l’information dans
l’espace et le temps ; l’entendement traite
ensuite cette information en lui appliquant
les catégories de la pensée, les concepts
purs.
TROISIÈME IDÉE IMPORTANTE : la métaphysique
traditionnelle est vaine. Il est impossible
de dépasser l’expérience par l’intelligence
pour découvrir l’essence des choses, parce
que les concepts de l’esprit humain s’appliquent
exclusivement aux données de l’expérience.
Pour le dire simplement, le logiciel de l’esprit
humain n’est pas fait pour comprendre l’essence
des choses, donc ça ne sert à rien d’essayer.
Par conséquent, la métaphysique ne permet
pas à l’homme d’affirmer quoi que ce
soit concernant l’âme, le monde ou Dieu.
Vous le savez peut-être, la Critique de la
raison pure de Kant est souvent étudiée
en tandem avec un autre livre, la Critique
de la raison pratique. Comme son titre l’indique,
la Critique de la raison pratique analyse,
elle, l’usage pratique, c’est-à-dire
l’usage lié à l’action — elle analyse
l’usage pratique, et non plus théorique,
de la raison.
________________
16ème référence : Phénoménologie de l’Esprit,
Hegel
Je me souviens d’une après-midi, il y a
une dizaine d’années, quand j’étais
en Master de philosophie à la Sorbonne : au
cours de cette après-midi, j’ai perdu plusieurs
heures à essayer de lire quelques pages seulement
(il y en a 700 au total) de la Phénoménologie
de l’Esprit de Hegel — mais j’ai abandonné…
Si vous voulez du mal à une personne, offrez-lui
ce livre. Non seulement elle aura mal à la
tête, mais en plus elle se sentira stupide
: le cocktail migraine et dépression.
Bon, mais alors pourquoi inclure cette référence
dans la liste ?
Eh bien parce qu’EN DÉPIT du caractère
illisible du propos, la Phénoménologie de
l’Esprit, l’œuvre maîtresse de Hegel,
une introduction à sa pensée — ce livre
illisible est devenu une des œuvres majeures
de la culture occidentale. Le système philosophique
qu’il expose a eu une énorme influence.
En simplifiant — et peut-être en caricaturant
— on peut dire que Hegel a donné Marx,
qui a donné l’idéologie communiste et
l’URSS.
Sur le plan purement intellectuel, les historiens
de la philosophie considèrent que la Phénoménologie
de l’Esprit de Hegel représente le point
culminant du courant du XIXe siècle qu’on
appelle « l’idéalisme allemand ». Ce
courant se nomme « idéalisme » parce que
son idée centrale est la conviction que c’est
notre esprit qui crée notre expérience de
la réalité. C’est la Critique de la raison
pure de Kant (dont je viens de vous parler)
qui est l’ouvrage fondateur de l’idéalisme
allemand.
Maintenant, quoi retenir de la Phénoménologie
de l’Esprit de Hegel ?
Deux idées sont importantes pour votre culture
générale.
PREMIÈRE IDÉE IMPORTANTE : la dialectique
hégélienne. Hegel donne à la dialectique,
c’est-à-dire à l’enchaînement logique
des choses, qui consiste en l’opposition,
puis le dépassement des contraires — Hegel
donne à cet enchaînement une ampleur inédite.
Il affirme tout d’abord que la dialectique
est le mouvement même de la pensée, la propriété
fondamentale du processus intellectuel, celle
qui donne sa pertinence et sa cohérence à
toute réflexion. Il avance ensuite que la
dialectique se déploie en fait dans la réalité
entière. Les événements se nieraient les
uns les autres avant de se réconcilier autour
d’une position ultime qui les intègre en
les dépassant.
SECONDE IDÉE IMPORTANTE de la Phénoménologie
de l’Esprit : la dialectique du maître
et de l’esclave. Hegel part du principe
que le besoin de reconnaissance est fondamental
chez l’être humain. Ainsi, lorsque deux
individus se rencontrent, leurs consciences
s’affrontent dans une lutte de prestige
: chacune cherche à ce que l’autre admette
sa valeur et renonce à la contester. S’ensuit
une lutte à mort pour la reconnaissance dont
le vainqueur est le maître et le vaincu l’esclave.
La logique de cet affrontement est le moteur
de l’histoire parce que la défaite contraint
le vaincu à travailler, c’est-à-dire à
transformer la nature.
Voilà pour la Phénoménologie de l’Esprit.
Si vous voulez vraiment lire du Hegel, je
vous conseille La raison dans l’Histoire,
qui est son ouvrage le plus accessible (j’ai
même pris du plaisir à le lire).
________________
17ème référence : Le Monde comme volonté
et comme représentation, Schopenhauer
Cette référence est l’œuvre maîtresse
de Schopenhauer, un philosophe allemand du
XIXe siècle qui aura une grande influence
sur les penseurs ultérieurs. On dit par exemple
qu’il est le maître de Nietzsche. C’est
aussi probablement lui qui a inspiré à Freud
les concepts d’inconscient et de refoulement.
Mais au-delà de la philosophie proprement
dite, les idées du Monde comme volonté et
comme représentation ont eu plus généralement
une énorme influence dans la culture occidentale,
notamment sur les jeunes créateurs déboussolés
dans le chaos de l’Europe après Napoleon
et déçus par les idéaux politiques du milieu
du XIXe siècle. Pour l’anecdote, l’acteur
Charlie Chaplin était fan de ce livre, qu’il
lisait et relisait. Je sais aussi que l’écrivain
Michel Houellebecq l’aime beaucoup.
Pourtant, c’était mal parti. Quand, à
seulement 30 ans, Schopenhauer a terminé
d’écrire Le Monde comme volonté et comme
représentation, il est persuadé, écrit-il
dans son carnet secret, d’avoir, je cite,
« apporté une solution au grand problème
de l’existence ». Mais personne n’achète
son chef-d’œuvre, et comme au même moment
Hegel accède à la gloire, Schopenhauer plonge
dans la dépression. La roue ne tournera qu’une
trentaine d’années plus tard : le succès
éditorial d’un autre livre amènera beaucoup
de gens à découvrir celui qui avait échoué
trente ans plus tôt.
Sur la forme, ce n’est pas toujours facile
à lire, mais Schopenhauer est bien plus accessible
que Hegel (bien sûr), que Kant, et même
que beaucoup de philosophes. C’est d’autant
plus vrai dans les traductions récentes du
Monde comme volonté et comme représentation.
​​Schopenhauer a eu une influence positive
sur le style philosophique. Si Hegel a donné
du crédit à la critique de ceux qui caricaturent
la philosophie comme un discours ésotérique,
trop obscur pour avoir de la valeur pour l’homme
ordinaire, Schopenhauer, lui, a montré qu’un
philosophe peut tout à fait dire clairement
des choses profondes. Nietzsche et Proust,
en particulier, admireront la pureté de sa
langue.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées essentielles
de cette référence ?
Comme l’indique le titre, la thèse du livre
est que 2 concepts suffisent à expliquer
la réalité : la Volonté (dont je vais vous
parler plus en détail), et la représentation,
c’est-à-dire le fait que nous sommes incapables
d’accéder à l’essence de la réalité
et que nous y vivons en nous en faisant une
image forcément infidèle (ce que nous croyons
être la réalité n’est que notre fantasme
de la réalité).
Dans le détail, 3 idées sont essentielles
pour votre culture générale.
PREMIÈRE IDÉE : la Volonté — Schopenhauer
appelle la Volonté, ou « vouloir-vivre », l’élan
essentiel de toute vie. Il y voit la force
primaire vitale et sans but, à la base de
tout phénomène, la force essentielle dont
relèvent toutes les autres forces particulières.
Elle s’exprime à la fois dans le monde
spirituel et dans le monde matériel. Elle
se manifeste depuis la pomme qui tombe de
l’arbre jusqu’au déplacement des planètes
en passant par ce qui est appelé, chez l’homme,
volonté (la faculté à l’origine des actes
délibérés).
DEUXIÈME IDÉE : l’illusion de l’amour
— Schopenhauer affirme que l’amour ne
vise en réalité que la procréation. Les
passions amoureuses servent uniquement la
perpétuation de l’humanité, d’où l’ampleur
des moyens qui leur sont consacrés. Schopenhauer
imagine même que l’espèce est guidée
par une forme d’eugénisme. Pour chaque
individu, il en existe un autre avec lequel
il peut s’unir pour produire l’être le
plus parfait du point de vue de l’espèce.
Plus la progéniture potentielle se rapproche
de l’idéal de pureté de l’humanité,
plus la passion sera forte, plus l’amour
semblera puissant.
TROISIÈME IDÉE ESSENTIELLE du Monde comme
volonté et comme représentation : le malheur
— L’individu qui, comme Schopenhauer,
a résolu le problème de l’existence — cet
individu comprend que l’homme est l’esclave
de la Volonté qui l’anime et qui le prive
de son libre arbitre. Enchaîné à son désir,
il ne fait qu’osciller entre la souffrance
de l’insatisfaction et l’ennui consécutif
à la satisfaction. Le pessimisme de Schopenhauer
est donc fondé sur l’idée que la Volonté
ne vise rien d’autre que sa propre affirmation.
Elle rend le monde intelligible, mais elle
en fait aussi le plus mauvais des mondes possibles.
________________
18ème référence : Manifeste du parti communiste,
Marx et Engels
Pourquoi ce livre est-il une référence philosophique
très importante ? Parce qu’en tant que
texte fondamental du marxisme, il a eu une
énorme influence dans le monde entier. Lorsque
Marx et Engels l’écrivent ensemble au milieu
du XIXe siècle, les communistes sont une
poignée de militants. Un siècle plus tard,
le marxisme est devenu l’idéologie d’une
moitié du monde — et beaucoup de gens pensent
alors qu’il réussira à conquérir la planète
entière.
Quel est le but du Manifeste du parti communiste
? Comme le titre l’indique, c’est un texte
militant : Marx et Engels l’écrivent en
1847 pour donner une base idéologique à
la Ligue des communistes, le groupe politique
clandestin qu’ils ont rejoint. Mais les
idées du Manifeste ne s’imposeront qu’à
partir du milieu des années 1860 à cause
de la répression politique et de la concurrence
entre les différents courants socialistes.
Sur la forme, c’est un livre court (il est
un petit peu plus long que le script de cette
vidéo). Le style est forcément plus simple
et plus clair que dans les autres travaux
théoriques de Marx, puisque tous les militants
doivent pouvoir comprendre le propos. Et forcément
aussi, puisque la finalité du texte est de
persuader afin de pousser à l’action, le
style est plus rhétorique. Par exemple, Marx
et Engels posent beaucoup de questions (près
de 30 en tout) afin de maintenir le niveau
d’attention du lecteur. Vous connaissez
peut-être aussi la célèbre injonction finale
: « Prolétaires de tous les pays, unissez-vous
! ».
Sur le fond, le fil conducteur du Manifeste
du parti communiste est l’idée qu’à
chaque époque, les modes de production et
d’échange déterminent l’histoire politique
et intellectuelle et que, donc, toute l’histoire
de l’humanité est « l’histoire de la
lutte des classes ». Cette vision de l’histoire
est ce qu’on appelle le « matérialisme
historique ». On utilise le terme « matérialisme
» parce que Marx — c’est son idée à
lui — Marx part du principe que ce sont
les situations réellement vécues par les
hommes, et non pas des abstractions, qui déterminent
les événements de l’histoire.
Marx et Engels expliquent dans le Manifeste
du parti communiste que la société a déjà
connu une succession de 4 modes de production
et de propriété : 1° le mode tribal, qui
implique la propriété communautaire ; 2°
le mode antique, lié à la propriété collective
; 3° le mode féodal, où la propriété
est liée à la hiérarchie des ordres dans
les campagnes et corporative en ville ; 4°
le mode bourgeois, caractérisé par la propriété
mobilière et le salariat. Et à chaque mode
correspond un couple oppresseurs opprimés
: les hommes libres et les esclaves, les patriciens
et les plébéiens, les barons et les serfs,
les maîtres de jurande et les compagnons,
les bourgeois et les prolétaires.
Mais pour Marx, l’évolution économique
est arrivée à un stade singulier qui est
la veille de la fin de l’histoire. La classe
dominée (les prolétaires) a désormais l’opportunité
de se libérer de la classe dominante (les
capitalistes) par une révolution, et de libérer
du coup toute la société de toute oppression.
Le Manifeste du parti communiste précise
le programme de la révolution prolétarienne.
Elle accouchera d’une brève dictature du
prolétariat permettant l’abolition de la
propriété privée et des classes sociales.
Marx imagine que ces deux mesures rendront
possible d’édifier le socialisme, après
quoi l’État, l’ancien instrument de domination
devenu obsolète, se dissoudra pour laisser
place à la société du communisme intégral.
Cette nouvelle société donnera naissance
à un homme nouveau, à la fois travailleur
et altruiste. Génial.
________________
19ème référence : Ainsi parlait Zarathoustra,
Nietzsche
Ainsi parlait Zarathoustra est une référence
philosophique très importante parce que ce
livre a bouleversé la pensée de l’Occident.
En effet, il remet en question la vision conventionnelle
de l’homme et il invite le lecteur à la
dépasser. C’est le fameux concept du « surhomme
», qui sera beaucoup caricaturé.
C’est vrai qu’à le lire au premier degré,
on a un peu l’impression d’avoir affaire
à un manifeste de développement personnel.
D’ailleurs, 30 ans après sa publication
initiale, le gouvernement allemand en a fait
imprimer 150 000 exemplaires et les a distribués,
avec la Bible, aux jeunes soldats de la Première
Guerre mondiale en pensant qu’ils en tireraient
une inspiration à se dépasser au combat.
Nietzsche avait un peu prévu cela : il se
faisait une haute idée de ce livre — il
l’a présenté comme un 5ème évangile
— et il pensait que les gens ne pourraient
pas le comprendre avant longtemps. Pourtant,
c’est de loin son livre le plus commenté
sur Amazon.
J’ai lu Ainsi parlait Zarathoustra quand
j’étais en école de commerce, et effectivement
il faut s’accrocher : c’est un poème
philosophique particulièrement obscur (sans
parler des problématiques de traduction…),
même s’il y a de beaux passages. L’écrivain
André Gide, qui était fan de Nietzsche,
n’a pas réussi à comprendre après 8 lectures.
Le style est poétique et prophétique (ce
qui irrite certains lecteurs). Nietzsche fait
de nombreuses allusions à la Bible et file
plein de métaphores liées au monde la nature,
métaphores qui invoquent les animaux, la
terre, l'air, le feu, l'eau, les corps célestes,
les plantes.
Sur le fond, le livre décrit le développement
spirituel de Zarathoustra. Ce nom est une
autre version du nom « Zoroastre », le prophète
et fondateur du zoroastrisme, l'ancienne religion
perse qui s’est épanouie en Iran au IIe
millénaire avant J.-C. Nietzsche a choisi
ce prophète parce qu’il aurait été le
premier à enseigner la doctrine morale des
deux principes du bien et du mal (doctrine
que Nietzsche invite à dépasser).
Je vous résume rapidement le parcours du
personnage. Comme Zarathoustra aime l’humanité,
il descend de sa montagne pour aller enseigner
la vérité du surhomme. Les gens le prennent
pour un fou — on pouvait s’y attendre
— donc il limite son enseignement à des
disciples. Problème (éternel dans l’histoire
de la pensée) : les disciples déforment
ses idées. Alors il combat ces disciples
infidèles, mais aussi les autres idéologues
qui maintiennent les hommes dans l’illusion.
Il comprend que c’est son amour pour l’humanité
qui l’empêche d’atteindre la vérité
la plus haute, donc il retourne en haut de
sa montagne. Il redescendra une dernière
fois pour guider un groupe d’hommes qui
ont créé une nouvelle religion en s’inspirant
de son enseignement.
L’IDÉE ESSENTIELLE du développement spirituel
de Zarathoustra, c’est celle qu’il veut
enseigner à l’humanité : l’idéal du
surhomme. Il ne s’agit pas d’un individu
immoral, dominateur et démesurément ambitieux,
mais d’un individualiste noble, courageux,
libre et créateur. Libéré de la morale
inhibitrice du christianisme comme de l’instinct
grégaire des êtres humains, le surhomme
crée ses propres valeurs. « Tu dois devenir
l’homme que tu es, écrit Nietzsche dans
Ainsi parlait Zarathoustra. Fais ce que toi
seul peux faire. Deviens sans cesse celui
que tu es, sois le maître et le sculpteur
de toi-même. »
________________
20ème référence : L'existentialisme est
un humanisme, Sartre
Cette référence est importante parce que
c’est la source de la grande mode intellectuelle
des Trente Glorieuses, « l’existentialisme
». ​​Le nom de ce nouveau courant signifie
que la vocation de l’homme est de définir
lui-même par ses actes ce qu’il entend
être. C’est dans ce sens que Sartre dit
que « l’existence précède l’essence
».
Historiquement, L'existentialisme est un humanisme
est le texte d’une conférence d’octobre
1945. Les organisateurs avaient beaucoup investi
pour en faire la pub dans les grands journaux
(notamment Le Monde, Le Figaro, Libération),
et ils se mordaient les doigts d’avoir accepté
un titre qui allait probablement faire fuir
les gens — mais la conférence sera un succès
culturel sans précédent. Bien que la salle
soit pleine à craquer et l’auditoire surexcité,
Sartre réussit un bon discours. Le lendemain,
la presse souligne son courage et donne ainsi
naissance à la mode intellectuelle de l’après-guerre.
Les mots « existentialisme » et « Sartre
» sont matraqués dans la presse en 1945.
Les éditeurs surfent sur la vague. Sartre
passe pour un nouveau Socrate.
La célèbre conférence a accouché d’un
petit livre de 100 pages tout aussi célèbre.
Au moment où j’écris ce script, il est
encore n°1 des ventes sur Amazon dans la
catégorie « Grandes doctrines et courants
philosophiques ».
Sur la forme, c’est forcément plus facile
à livre qu’un vrai livre de théorie philosophique,
puisque c’est une conférence prononcée
en direct (de surcroît sans notes, comme
Sartre aimait à le faire). Le style est clair,
il a une élégance littéraire — Sartre
était aussi un romancier — et on retrouve
son fameux sens de la formule, qui est pour
beaucoup dans le succès de la conférence.
Sur le fond, l’objectif de la conférence
était de répondre aux critiques adressées
à l’époque à l’existentialisme. Considéré
par bien des gens, dans le contexte de l’après-guerre,
comme un parfait antihumaniste, Jean-Paul
Sartre veut convaincre du contraire : l’existentialisme
n’est pas une philosophie de l’égoïsme
; c’est en réalité un humanisme, c’est-à-dire
une philosophie qui considère que l’homme
et les affaires humaines sont ce qui a le
plus de valeur et ce qu’il y a de plus noble.
L’IDÉE ESSENTIELLE de L'existentialisme
est un humanisme est la radicalité de la
liberté humaine. Le nom de la doctrine, « l’existentialisme
» — ce mot oppose l’existence et l’essence.
Comme je vous l’ai dit, Sartre affirme que
l’existence précède l’essence, c’est-à-dire
qu’aucune fonction ni aucun destin ne sont
fixés pour l’individu, ni ne déterminent
sa vie à l’avance. « L’homme existe
d’abord, explique Sartre, se rencontre,
surgit dans le monde, et il se définit après
».
En particulier, l'homme ne peut pas se raccrocher
ni à une nature humaine qui le déterminerait
et l'enserrerait, ni à Dieu, qui n'existe
pas. Par conséquent, il est radicalement
libre. Cela implique qu’il se définit
lui-même en agissant, qu’il s'invente
lui-même. L’homme est « le projet », pose
Sartre, qu'il choisit pour lui-même.
Sartre répond plus précisément à l’accusation
d’égoïsme en ajoutant que la définition
que l’homme choisit pour lui-même influence
la manière dont tous les autres hommes se
définissent. L’individu doit donc aussi
assumer une part de la responsabilité collective,
étant donné qu’il contribue forcément,
par son influence, au monde et à la société.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Si vous ne l’avez pas fait,
je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez découvrir
LES CINQ SECRETS
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
et SANS VOUS PRENDRE
LA TÊTE.
Inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.